I'm right you guys time for another
movie retrospective and we're finally
getting around to this movie that I've
been wanting to do for a long time I
keep saying that a lot don't I yeah
we've only done one other Dario Argento
movie and that was Suspiria and actually
when we did that one I had to do that
one by myself because Tom was out of
town visiting his dad when we did that
one but I've been wanting to do some
other ones and this one is pretty much
was pretty much at the top of the list
this is deep red aka profile it also
also I've also seen it called the
hatchet murders or deep red hatchet
murders because and I'll kind of go into
it a little bit later but the us cut and
the European cut are very very different
like the u.s. cut is much much shorter
and actually the one that is currently
on shudder as we're recording this is I
believe the US version because the
longer European cut the scenes that were
taken out it was like 20 minutes like 21
minutes of scenes that were taken out
they never dubbed them into English so
when you watch the European cut if you
watch the one that's dubbed into English
then every now and then there'll be a
scene that's in Italian you know that
just has subtitles because they never
bothered doing those so that was I think
the arrow was the company that did like
this big special edition like to disk
set and all this other kind of stuff
that all these really cool lobby cards
and stuff and they actually give you the
option of watching the European catches
with the Italian seems like inserted
back in there with English subtitles so
I'm going by the u.s. cut because I have
not seen the longer one like I said I've
had it on DVD and I have watched it on
shudder but I've never had like the
longer version most of the scenes that
were taken out I think were mostly just
character building type scenes so a lot
of that was taken out I don't know if a
lot of gore was taken out because the
u.s. got still pretty gory but so deep
red was came out in 1975 and is
generally considered not only probably
one of the best if not the best giallo
movies
ever made now obviously Dario Argento
had made some giallo movies before his
first his directorial debut which came
out in 1970 the bird with the crystal
plumage was a huge huge success and then
he did another one in 1971 called the
cat-o'-nine-tails and also in 1971 he
did a third one that was called for
flies on grey velvet this is called his
animal trilogy there's a computer
program that can emulate the title of a
Java boy it's one of my favorite like I
will entertain myself for hours that I
think you can just google it I think
it's still there called just the giallo
name and plot generator it'll generate a
plot - which is cool yeah but it's just
like the names it comes up with or just
pretty much because they'll say I love
jell-o movies and I love the titles of
them like black belly of the tarantula I
mean like how [ __ ] rad is that and
they like it just had like the best
[ __ ] posters and all this other kind
of stuff but I just love the [ __ ]
title and I'm super broke but yes so he
had actually kind of made his name doing
these jell-o movies like I said that
were called his animal trilogy and then
in you know after those ones came out
yes they were very successful and stuff
but then he thought well you know in the
early 70s there was like a huge you know
rash of giallo movies they were just
everywhere there was like a hundred of
them that came out like in just a couple
year period so he thought that people
would be getting sick of the genre so
what he decided to do after four flies
on grey velvet was he said well I'm
gonna make a different kind of movie he
made something that was like a comedic
Western which isn't totally crazy
because Dario Argento did used to do
screenwriting for spaghetti westerns and
stuff like that so he made a comedy
western type thing called five days in
Milan which was a critical and
commercial failure so and honestly I had
forgotten all about them okay and I have
[ __ ] tons of books about Dario Argento
so I know like about all his movies and
stuff like that but I had totally
forgotten that that one existed and I've
never even seen it so he decided after
that he said well I'm gonna go back to
the jello John genre and ended up making
as I said what is considered probably
the best jello ever made in deep red
it's probably good that he went back to
Jolla because I'm getting in there with
you Sergio Leone yeah you know with the
good the bad the ugly Fistful of Dollars
a few dollars more and evidently you
know watching a lot of the documentaries
on it in there evidently sergio leone
was really the only good italian western
director the rest of them were they were
just you know made extremely cheaply
they were just they weren't special yeah
when you look at a Sergio Leone movie it
looks like it has real characters and
there's a real story there cuz there is
yeah but a lot of the other Italian ones
we weren't really like that I was
reading something interesting about the
Italian film industry they said because
I mean they have like a rather large
film industry but because they don't
have like in Hollywood they have like
lots and lots and lots of different
Studios like working on different types
of projects and lots of indie Studios
and stuff like that
they said whereas particularly in the
70s in Italy you would get like one
movie would come out and it was like
super successful and then for whatever
reason like everyone would make one they
even had a word for I can't remember at
the Italian where it is but it was
essentially a word meaning like
streamlet where you were just like oh
well made a jell-o movie and it was like
a huge success just he's making that
yeah and so like a lot of them came out
now I'm not saying that all of those
were bad because a lot of jell-o movies
that came out in the late 60s early 70s
because really I would argue I mean
Dario obviously didn't do the first ones
Mario Bava is probably credited with
doing you know the girl who knew too
much and blood and black lace and stuff
like that but you know they just got
super popular but a lot of those were
good I mean because I really liked
yellow movies so I've seen a lot of the
kind of lesser-known examples you know
they made like house with the Laughing
windows and you know there was just a
lot of really good ones but so he
decides to go back and make another one
so he made a deep red now this is
interesting movie in a lot of ways in
some ways and I've seen some reviewers
say that it's essentially a remake of
the bird with a crystal plumage which it
isn't really it does have the same like
a similar plot structure and actually a
lot of jell-o movies kind of have this
where you know the the whole conceit of
the movie is that there's someone who is
not an investigator they're usually a
foreigner or a tourist or someone like
that and they witness a murder and can't
do anything to prevent it and then they
see like a clue or they keep rerunning
the scene like the murder in their mind
because they're haunted that there's
like one clue that they can't
contextualize or they can't get a hold
on it that's gonna solve the whole thing
or say who the killer is the same thing
happened like I said in bird with a
crystal plumage where you know the guy
was like he sees someone getting
murdered in an art gallery and he is
like trapped between these two glass
windows and he can't help the victim and
then you know the whole movie he's
trying to remember this little detail so
the same thing happens in deep red our
main character is named Marcus Daly and
he's actually an English pianist he
teaches at a conservatory he's a jazz
musician also and the interesting thing
about Argento choosing to put David
Hemmings who played Marc Daly into this
movie is because he's making a reference
to the Michelangelo Antonioni classic
blow up which came out in 1966 because
that whole movie was about a guy played
by David Hemmings who photographed what
he didn't know was a murder at the time
but then later on when he developed the
photos he saw that there was a murder
and he was like trying to figure out the
clues and it's a very similar kind of
thing to this so he put that guy in this
movie ten years later as an homage to
that movie so he lives in this building
he's coming home one night and he sees a
woman who was actually a psychic her
name is Olga and she is being murdered
in her apartment now he rushes up there
and tries to help her cuz she like lives
one apartment above him but by the time
he gets to her apartment she's already
dead it's too late
but for the entire movie he's thinking
because when he looked up in the window
he thought he saw this painting that was
like in this hallway but then when he
went up to the apartment and the cops
came and everything like that he thought
that the painting was gone so he's
talking to his friend Carlo and Carlo
was like well maybe the killer removed
it because it was important like to you
know identify them or something like
that so through the whole thing like
through his investigation he's kind of
trying to figure out like what's the
significance of this painting if indeed
it was a painting and all this other
kind of stuff so it was a little
detailed that he's trying to remember
now one thing and a lot of critics
talked about this movie too in relation
to Dario Argento did a lot of stuff in
his movies like playing with gender
politics and interestingly a lot of his
movies and this is you have to think
this is like early early 70s a lot of
his movies have gay or trans characters
and they are not played for laughs
they're just played like as normal
characters which was actually pretty
strange a pretty like progressive for
the time but he likes to kind of play
around with that and deep-red is a
really good example of that because it
you know in a lot of giallo movies the
the protagonist is you know the person
that witnesses the murder or who is a
victim or narrowly escapes and is trying
to like figure out the murder because
the police are generally ineffectual or
don't care or something like that that's
another very common trope in these types
of movies but it but it's usually
they're they're usually still very
sexist it's usually like a man and he's
like Bossin the chicks around and the
chicks are just all victims and stuff
like that now deep-red inverts that
trope because Marc Daly is you know he's
kind of the driving force of the plot
sort of because he's investigating the
murder but in a lot of ways he's really
ineffectual now this is something that
they do a lot of GLI movies where it's
this kind of whole thing about male
impotence like they can't they see a
murder and they can't do anything to
prevent it and then
you know the killers coming after them
and [ __ ] like that but it's really kind
of amplified in deep red because mark
Daly's character is pretty much
subservient to this reporter who starts
tagging along with him and investigating
herself and her name is Gianna Brett see
now she's played bar Darian Darian
Nickelodeon ously got into a
relationship with Dario Argento later on
they had a very long and very
contentious relationship it was like in
all the tabloids over there I think they
were together for 10 11 years something
like that and very famously their
daughter is Asiata jente who later
became a act and actress and a director
in her own right but so this but this is
the first movie that they did together
and dari and Nickelodeon and came up
with the idea for Suspiria which was the
one that came out after this so she is
kind of like a go getting ballbusting
type of girl and he is kind of like I'm
not gonna say he's like a wussy or
anything but it's like she's always
he'll he'll says [ __ ] like you know Oh
everyone knows like men are stronger bla
bla bla and she's like oh yeah that she
wants to arm-wrestle him and she wins
and then he starts saying oh you cheated
and all this other kind of crap but it's
like in a lot of ways she ends up kind
of being the hero I mean you know a
house catches fire she pulls him out of
it but then there's like all this little
stuff to you like she's always like
busting his balls about hope what a
Wimpy is she has this car that she
always drives and then like the
passenger seat is broken so whenever he
gets in there it like makes he sits like
way lower than her so it's like always
that kind of thing so there's always
this kind of like gender politics thing
going on in there which is actually very
funny and elevates it a lot and I think
that the reason that a lot of people
like deep bread is because the those two
characters like play off each other so
well
which you don't see a lot in gln movies
I think a lot of the characterization is
kind of lacking because it's mostly like
a plot driven you know mystery story but
this one is kind of fun like watching
these two banter with each other and
stuff like that
also like I said they kind of play
around with you know I don't want to
give too much away in case you haven't
seen it because you know this is a kind
of thing where it's like a murder
mystery it's very intricately plotted
and you have to kind of like pay
attention to all the little details in
there and stuff like that to figure out
sue I don't want to like say who the
killer is or like spoilered or anything
like that but they kind of lead you down
one path to believe it's once one person
and that is not like part of the genre
yeah yeah do that one of the things that
I do like about the Italian film scene
from that era is that you could really
tell that these movies were being made
by basically a small clique of loosely
organized people artists basically maybe
yes they weren't in like a like a
Hollywood system yeah it was a scene you
know and it was a lot like the Japanese
scene to the Japanese filmmaking scene
was similar they even kind of like
there's a lot of crossover they worked
on movies together
they would I guess you could say they
were industries of similar size and
similar budget to and I've seen you know
a lot of documentaries on the Japanese
you know and the Italians and kind of
agreed that even the people who were
involved it was a it was a bunch of
shady characters really making these
yeah this wasn't really like you know
honest business but you neither is
really Hollywood but that's that's in a
studio systems anybody yeah a lot more
organized there was unions involved the
Japanese and the Italians scenes were
kind of fly-by-night but they had a good
Flair and every now and then you'd get a
good director and because he was free to
do whatever he wanted he could make a
really cool flick and he could make it
look the way he wanted to didn't have to
go through a committee and you know a
good example would be you know Sergio
Leone and yeah and some Dario Argento
you know dead dead those movies came out
exactly the way they wanted him to they
may have not been super organized they
didn't maybe have huge budgets but they
had their own style yeah there it's very
based around like auteur
making where's kind of like one or two
people's vision medline like a committee
really big budget homemade flick is what
they're like with an artistic director
and usually like family businesses and
in Japan it was kind of like almost
Samia cuza involved - yeah they were
artists but they were also shady money
men you know yeah behind a lot of this
stuff making a quick buck that kind of
crap I mean the cool thing about deep
red is that one it was a huge influence
I feel like it's interesting because it
bridges the gap between Dario Argento's
early giallo
films and his later ones which win on a
more supernatural direction because deep
red is pretty much a standard giallo
except it does have like the character
of Olga the German woman who is the
first victim of the murderer she does
actually have psychic powers but they
kind of take pains to say it's not
really magic she can't tell the future
but she can she can like hear other
people's thoughts there's a very famous
scene where she's were her and her to
like handlers are parapsychologist or
whatever like in a stage and she can
hear someone's thoughts the murderer is
in the audience or a murderers in the
audience and she can hear it and she
starts freaking out which is why the
killer targets her because she knows who
they are because she can hear their
thoughts so like I said the movie that
came out after this obviously very
famously was Suspiria which is pretty
much which I wouldn't even really call a
jello because it's not really a murder
mystery per se it's more like a
supernatural fairy tale nightmare type
of thing Suspiria was a pretty flick I
liked how it looked the lighting yeah it
looked good it is really one of the most
beautiful movies ever made even though I
must say you know I must tell tell the
audience that jello is not my thing
that's that's Jenny's thing that's why
she's doing most of talking right now
they're not really my kind of movies
they don't really they don't really give
me what I'm looking for but you know I'm
just one person you know Jay
Jenny loves it I do understand I
understand their appreciation for it
though you know I mean they look really
good
yeah and they do do what they're
supposed to do at least the ones that
we're talking about the ones that you
show me yeah yes it's also it's known
that basically all these jello movies
and all these spaghetti westerns most of
them were crap but they never left Italy
they stayed in Italy the ones that ended
up leaving Italy the ones that we saw
were the good those are the good one
those were the good ones yeah and like I
said I've seen a really lot of good yeah
Gela movie some of them are better I
don't think any of them are as good as
deep bread I think it's probably the
best one but I have seen a lot of really
really really good ones and actually
shudder has a bunch of them now I think
they have they might have blood-stained
butterfly and a few other ones but and I
should say too that the giallo Chandra
was like a huge huge influence on
American slasher films and particularly
a huge influence on John Carpenter yeah
you can see a lot of jell-o elements in
Halloween yeah actually Halloween -
pretty much I'm not gonna say stole but
I'm gonna say Oh majd one of the deaths
in deep-red where a woman was like
boiled alive like in a bathtub full of
like steaming hot water yes some of the
ones that she showed me it fits right in
there you you start seeing in movies you
know yeah Halloween what was that one
dead buried yeah that was kind of very
jolly like yeah I mean you can you can
see the cross over where it came from
and I think John Carpenter - because I
should mention that deep-red has an
awesome awesome score this was actually
the first time that Dario Gento worked
with goblin who of course would become
kind of an expert in X and X trick ibly
linked with his movies later on but um
this was the first time that they worked
together and I love this score really
second only to Suspiria like you know
nothing's gonna beat this Hesperia score
because I [ __ ] love that piece of
those pieces of music but this one is
almost as good
and I think John Carpenter was really
influenced by the score of this as well
that particularly those plinky strings
kinda stuff he was influenced by a lot
of attacks oh yeah and my one of my
favorite carpenter flicks of course is
escape from New York yeah and that thing
is lit like a gel and like a jolly movie
it is Dario Argento all the colored
lights the way it's lit and the way they
treated the color and because they had
some new cameras with new film that
could shoot at night I mean it just look
pretty beautiful
yeah it's night shots with blue and
green lights in the background it just
looked really cool you know and we you
know we saw John whit - last night and
it kind of harkens back to that that
that's what yeah with those really
saturated colors yeah
like here's a big stream of like pink
light and here's a rock ring of like
green noticing it last night wears a
green and gold and green and gold and
blue over and over again yeah yeah and I
think a lot of that does come from
particularly Suspiria because that was
like the most out does not outlandish in
a bad way but like the most outlandish
example of it because that was just like
this crazy like fantasy candy color yeah
type of thing but oh I should say to
that David Cronenberg actually emerged
the psychic seen in deep red with them
all sitting in at the table with like
all the red in the background first
scanners I noticed that in this era of
the 60s and the 70s the Italians really
knew how to shoot color yeah I had a
light a set and on the other hand the
Japanese knew how to shoot action do you
notice that yeah they're they're just
kind of like they had to separate you
know specialties and then you know some
in in more modern films like when John
wick three they were doing both yeah
they had kind of like Italian style
lighting with a lot of Japanese style
action yeah it's almost like kind of an
its merged yeah yeah that's kind of
marriage of state way of putting it yeah
American film is kind of you know taking
the best of both of those two genres and
have kind of merged yeah and into
American film now I'm gonna say too that
there's a very famous scene in deep red
and if you've seen it you probably know
what I'm talking about where the one guy
he's about to be victimized by the
killer and all of a sudden he's in his
office and all of a sudden the door
busts open and strangely
this little walking like ventriloquist
dummy looking thing just like walks in
that no reason it's like that's not the
killer the killer comes from another
place but I think that in a way that
seemed like kind of the inspiration for
saw like with the little doll coming in
on the bike and stuff it's like I think
they kind of like omage that scene
pretty overtly because the dummy looks
kind of similar it's weird you know you
have some of this classic film it didn't
really inspire audiences too much they
don't remember him but all the directors
remembered that you're seeing it now
well it's just kind of like you know
back in the old days like when the Sex
Pistols played in Manchester yeah and
like there was only what like a hundred
people there maybe not even that many
but every single person that was at that
gig started a band right you know what I
mean this is always Joy Division the
Smiths the fall it's like you know what
I mean so it's almost kind of like if
you're into if you're a creative person
and you create things yourself
obviously [ __ ] is gonna be more
influential to you than it is yeah makes
an impact on you right and I think the
same thing going back even further in
time happened with you know like The
Velvet Underground who didn't sell many
records while they were around but
everybody that bought that record was
inspired by them to form their own bands
and they kind of you know became like
this bigger thing later on I remember
being a kid watching these movies when
they were a lot fresher and a lot newer
I didn't really notice all these
interest intricacies that we're talking
about now didn't I really didn't really
the audiences didn't know it yeah didn't
notice it at the time although you know
directors did yeah you know it's kind of
cool well like I said if you know
something about like it like I said if
you know some about music if you know
something making or art or whatever you
know obviously you're gonna be way more
into it because you're gonna see oh I
see what you did there you know what I
mean
yeah and that's why when you see deep
red which came out of 1975 you're gonna
pick up like all this stuff you know if
you're so inclined or if you're a movie
maker you're gonna see oh you can see
all the threads Arouca John Carpenter
and David Cronenberg omage that and you
can see where they're coming from with
it because they were the ones that were
watching it and studying it yeah you
know coming from that point of view yeah
it was a different time back then you
know they didn't have a lot of computer
technology everything it was kind of
handcrafted yeah we planned out in
storyboards and then you shoot it and
then you you did it on the cutting room
floor yeah you know so it was just a few
guys working trying to make something
that looked really cool yeah now you do
it on like post-production with
computers yeah you know which that's
cool too it can be done right or you
know sometimes it isn't done right but
from what I've been seeing lately you
know it they're doing it right
yeah I feel like people like filmmakers
nowadays are maybe going back to more
old school just better
yeah it looks better it looks good and I
mean the thing about deep red like I
said that you know and why a lot of
people call this as his Dario Argento's
first masterpiece a lot of it has to do
with how he frames his shots the camera
movement stuff like that the camera in
it is very fluid he also plays a lot
with and and I feel like David Lynch
does this too where he almost kind of
like I want to say he like shows the
wires like he shows the artifice of
filmmaking particularly in the scenes
where like when you see the psychics at
the table and like you know the the
camera approaches a drape and like the
drape pulls aside as though you're just
about to watch a play and there's a
scene with Marc Daly and his friend
Carlo they're talking in the street you
know right before the murder happens and
right behind them is a diner with people
posed in it just like the Edward Hopper
painting
Nighthawks and this is not like
commented upon but what he's doing is
he's trying to establish he's almost
like making it like this is a movie
wink-wink because the whole point of the
movie is you know the how you can't
trust your memory how you can't just
like the point of blow-up was you know
the difference between like photography
and real life this is the same
kind of thing you know how the fal
ability of memory and all that and you
know the past coming back to haunt you
and all this other kind of stuff so so
he always wants to like one remove like
everything's like almost on a stage set
even though it's not it was actually
filmed in Turin the funny thing I was I
have a book called profond Oh Argento
that has like a lot of interviews with
him and he's talking about all of his
movies and stuff and he said that he
chose to Rin to film deep-red because at
the time it had the highest
concentration of Satanists in Italy and
he just thought that was neat so he's
that's why he nothing I'd like to
mention is just the Edit of Italian
movies they're very different the way a
story unfolds in Italian movie is not
like it it not like it unfolds in an
American story
like for instance that and sometimes
it's quite modern like this there could
be bad the ugly the Edit on that that
I'm watching now it's unfolding not like
a 60s Western the 60s Western an
American one kind of felt like a episode
of bonanza yeah okay I know she said you
know Donna but the way this one is
unfolding it looks it's very very modern
a lot more like Quentin Tarantino yeah
like that you know I mean more more of
an action pace yeah yeah no I like it
it's it's you know I think they did
contribute to to you know the telling of
Western stories because they're there in
Italy yeah you know and they're
contributing to Western so you know like
you see it and free in the Unforgiven
you know and you see in in High Plains
Drifter you know I mean that's a lot of
spaghetti western in that well open
anything
I always thought particularly about the
American Italian film industries is that
it feeds off each other yeah you know
what I mean it seems like the Italians
were really inspired by Alfred Hitchcock
you know and then they kind of made all
these sort of Hitchcockian type movies
and then you know all the giallo movies
that they made
which were kind of like I said inspired
by Hitchcock also inspired by you know
British and American crime writers but
then you know they made these movies and
those movies ended up you know
contributing to the American slasher
genre because all the directors over
here we're seeing these movies on VHS
you know all these weird because at the
time in the 70s and 80s Italian movies
were way way gory er then you could get
away with in American film and the thing
about this about deep red in particular
it doesn't have a huge amount of death
scenes but the ones they have are pretty
nasty something that Dario Argento has
said he's like you know I wanted all the
deaths in this like all the kill scenes
to be relatable by the average viewer
he's like the average viewer can't
relate to being shot for example however
you can relate to scalding yourself with
hot water or having your teeth like hit
on the corner of like a desk or
something like that so there's a lot of
close-ups you know the one guy that dies
you know and he's just all his teeth get
like bang done like every available like
or it's really like uncomfortable to
watch and he's like I wanted that kind
of relatable element to the kills you
know an old guy gets killed by first she
gets a meat cleaver but then she gets
like hung over her head gets thrown
through and she gets hurt like sliced up
by broken glass and all this other kind
of stuff so they wanted to do something
kind of visceral like that but yeah so
yeah that and I was gonna say too I
think I mentioned this a little bit at
the beginning that the Italian cut of
this of deep red actually runs a hundred
and twenty six minutes but the u.s. cut
is twenty-one minutes shorter so as far
as I know I think all that they took out
they took out a lot of character
building scenes like scenes between you
know Daria Daria Nickelodeon Eric tur
and David Hemmings his character where
established established more of this
kind of banter that they had and like
them like their romance and stuff like
that I think a little bit of the gore
was trimmed
I know in the UK version they actually
took out there is one kind of disturbing
scene that I have a hard time watching
but there's this little girl in it and
she has taken a lizard and like poked a
pin like through its neck and then like
stuck it to the ground so it's like
struggling to get out and it can't get
out and as far as I know that's a real
lizard because they didn't have like
animal claws like and as to which if
you'll see if you've seen Cannibal
Holocaust you know how horribly horribly
horribly that can go wrong but yeah so
as far as I know that's a real lizard so
the UK kind of cut that out because
that's animal cruelty the u.s. cut still
has it but I don't really like to watch
that part because the poor little lizard
is just like you know you can tell
they're struggling the italians were an
example of what happens when you usually
let people run wild they did yeah there
were no rules they left these directors
just run [ __ ] wild what ends up
happening is most of the most of the
[ __ ] you're gonna get his crap it's crap
they're just knocking it out they're
just trying to make movies this is
dinner at a time when a lot of Italians
didn't have televisions so they had they
all had theaters and it only cost a few
you know 30 or 40 cents to go to the
theater and they would go you know every
day of the week so there was a constant
demand for new movies and so most of it
was just churning out crap but there
were also guys are a real artists and
they would just come out with this weird
[ __ ] that ended up influencing the world
had it happened in the United States at
that time
the studio's we said no we can't have
that the lighting looks funny we don't
want that yeah it doesn't have this so
they do allow genius to rise or certain
elements of genius yeah and you know
other directors said hey you got that
right oh they got that right I'm gonna
take this I'm gonna take that I'm gonna
take this so that's what the Italians
gave to the world when it came to come
came to film yeah ya know and it should
be said that I mean deep red is pretty
much a standard yellow so it does
actually the plot does actually make
sense this was the film that he made
before Suspiria which a lot of people
say doesn't make much sense because he's
more worried about
no the visuals than he is the actual
plot I don't know if I'd necessarily
agree with that I mean it mostly makes
sense this has deep red has a couple
like what the [ __ ] moments in it like I
said like that doll coming in but that's
like so cool and like so effective it's
like who [ __ ] cares if it doesn't
make any sense I don't care but you just
like have to roll with it just because
it's a Daario movie you know what I mean
it's just kind of like a lot of Italian
movies at the time particularly post
Suspiria you just kind of have to roll
with that's just how they do man
yeah and like I said it's it's hard to
say too because you know a lot of times
what you're seeing in the United States
or the UK with the English dub is not
what the Italian audience would have
seen and one thing in particular like I
said I've never seen the European cut
but I know what scenes they took out and
most of it is because of this wonderful
book right here if you're into Dario
Argento I'm sure you already own this
but if you don't it's Maitland
mcdonoughs broken mirrors broken mines
where she pretty much talks about she's
you know a film historian and she just
talks about pretty much every Dario
Argento movie and like analyzes the hell
out of it and it's really really
fascinating but so she describes a lot
of the scenes that weren't in the the US
dub and a lot of the dubbing too is kind
of problematic because she lose a lot of
the subtlety you know for example the
character of Carlo and deep-red who is
outed at some point later on these like
and he calls himself a [ __ ] they're
like that's not what the original
Italian said it was much subtler like I
had strange sexual preferences or he
said somethings like that that I'm a
freakazoid that implied something else I
mean you know what I mean whereas in
English we just said he just said yeah
I'm a [ __ ] in a drunken yeah there was
a lot a lot of the English dubs so
there's Italian movies did the
continuity was bad and just and just
like you said the diction and [ __ ] you
know like yeah you know the terminology
was pretty tacky yeah and honestly it
was you know that's not what the
original you know story was about and
sometimes like I said the translation is
bad so you're not getting all the
subtleties of life I mean you're always
gonna lose that when you're translating
from one language to another
even in the subtitles but honestly I
think eventually I like to eat bread so
much that I would probably invest in the
arrow like to disc set so I could just
watch the whole thing in Italian with
English subtitles
Clint Eastwood's said making movies with
the Italians it's kind of difficult
difficult because what would happen is
is that you'd shoot scenes and they
would lose the audio yeah and they would
also kind of lose the script of the
script drifted it changed and then you
had to come back months later okay and
do your voiceover writer scene yes but
you forgot what you said in that scene
right okay oh the story had been changed
and they no longer had the script so he
said a lot of actors had to had to take
notes of what had happened because in
certain shots they're turning away from
the camera they're still talking and you
forgot what it was that you said that
you said yeah so some stuffs was just
kind of ad-libbed after the fact in the
voiceover yeah and sight yeah I can see
that and sometimes the original actor
wasn't available to do the voice-over or
they said screw it we never used the
original actor for the voice to ever
depend on who the director was yeah so
you had like a guy who did never shot
the movie never read the script trying
to do the voice-over for a guy who
that's not him on camera he goes and he
wasn't even there when they were you
know so that was another thing you know
you yeah you know that's nothing you
have to you have to take an account with
ease attack right there were not they
were not professional and they were not
highly organized man yeah although like
I said I don't think deep-red really
suffers from that deep bread does have a
pretty straightforward plot it like I
said it is very intricately product
plotted it's a murder mystery but one
thing does lead on to the next thing you
know what I mean it's like he finds one
clue and that leads him to another clue
and that leads him to another clue so it
does generally make a linear kind of
sense as long as you're paying attention
to what people say and I saw the
interview the Clint said people had
warned him it said you better take notes
you know what I mean of what you said
because they're gonna come back
four months from now and tell you to
redo that and you won't know and you all
remember what it is that's exactly what
happened you said you know in Fistful of
Dollars some of those lines he with he
was saying when he wasn't facing the
camera he didn't know what he said so
they just kind of had to like well I
must have said something like this yeah
it's weird
well at least he was like the original
actor like I can't imagine being brought
in it's like a voiceover actor and I'm
wrong you weren't even on you weren't
even on set yeah it's just yeah just
figure it out yeah and hey you would
think it would be easy well he must have
said this is but the thing is is they're
doing the voice-over for a little 10
seconds snippets and they're all doing
it out of context then later it's
putting it's assembled yes you know it
was crazy
all right I think we've gone on enough
about deep red a caper fun Darrell so go
check it out if you like Italian cinema
and have not seen it like I said
generally regarded as one of the best if
not the best giallo
movies ever made and I would tend to
agree with that assessment so go check
it out it's on shudder right now at
least the US version is and remember if
you like the show like share subscribe
about all your social media if you'd
like to financially support the show you
can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation remember our movie
retrospectives just like this one come
out every Friday and our 13 o'clock
matinee which is three new movies in the
theater that comes out every Sunday and
our regular episodes which usually
paranormal stuff or true crime stuff
come out every Tuesday so check them all
out we will see you next time bye